l'autre blanchemaison bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors pour commencer des précisions sur
le contexte pourquoi les hostilités
reprennent tel maintenant entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
mais il est probable que le président de
l'azerbaïdjan monsieur iduma lief a
considéré que finalement le moment était
propice
parce qu'il ya longtemps que
l'azerbaïdjan veut prendre sa revanche
de l'accord de cessez le feu de 1994 qui
avait été négocié sous les auspices et
avec la médiation de la russie après six
ans de conflit et 30000 morts donc et
qui avait coûté à peu près 13 % de son
territoire à l'azerbaïdjan alors
pourquoi est ce que c'est le terrain
serait favorable aujourd'hui pour
monsieur alief eh bien d'abord parce que
il a besoin de trouver une diversion
patriotique pour sa population
actuellement l'économie de la verdad
gens souffrent de la baisse des prix du
pétrole l'économie
ne va pas bien et naturellement là comme
ailleurs la crise du coc vie 19
n'arrange pas les choses
donc il a pu mobiliser sa population
déjà que l'arménie a fait la même chose
au sens psychologique au sens propre les
deux les deux populations sont tout à
fait mobiliser alors l'azerbaïdjan a
saisi une autre opportunité c'est que
monsieur erdogan soutient à fond
l'azerbaïdjan est probablement
l'encouragent même à reprendre ce que
l'arménie a pu conquérir pendant la
guerre de 88 à 94
ça veut dire le la poche du nagorny
karabakh du haut karabakh dans laquelle
vivent
cent cinquante mille arméniens
qu'entouraient en plein milieu du
territoire azéri mais les arméniens ont
également obtenu en 94 de d'avoir une
zone tenteront tout autour qu'il
contrôle pour assurer la sécurité et
diot du haut karabakh et c'est cette
zone tampon qui fait l'objet
naturellement de l'offensive de la
verbal gens qui voudraient récupérer
cette zone tampon
sinon le nagorny karabakh lui même est
ce que ce soir claude blanche maison on
peut parler de guerre ouverte
oui parce que si on écoute les deux
parties on entend le premier ministre
arménien dire que cette terre est une
terre sacré pour l'arménie que c'est
donc une cause sacrée et qu'il faut se
battre et se battre jusqu'à la dernière
goutte de sang et puis du côté azéri
on invoque le droit international en
disant que l'azerbaïdjan veut recouvrer
le contrôle de l'intégrité de son
territoire à l'intérieur de ses
frontières et on voit bien que
l'azerbaïdjan qui est devenu puissant
entre temps grâce à la manne pétrolière
au pétrole découvert en mer caspienne
n'entend pas
baisser la garde et céder aux
injonctions internationale il veut
encore une fois conquérir tout ou partie
de ce qui a été conquis en 94 par les
arméniens et que l'azerbaïdjan par avait
dû accepter à l'époque parce qu'il était
en état de faiblesse
c'était d'ailleurs le père de monsieur
aliev qui était à l'époque le président
de l'azerbaïdjan et le fils veut venger
le père alors la france la russie des
états unis parlent qu'à l'instant de
menaces inacceptables pour la stabilité
de la région
elle les puissants extérieur quel rôle
ont-elles aujourd'hui d'abord la turquie
est clair que la turquie joue un rôle
déstabilisateur puisqu'elle encourage
manifestement laver rebattre gens dans
cette affaire dans cette opération
militaire et les propos qui sont tenus à
ankara sont des propos très guerrier la
visite de monsieur stoltenberg le
secrétaire général de l'otan aujourd'hui
ne change pas grand chose parce que le
milieu des affaires étrangères très
calmement à 10 mais pour qui une
solution il faut que l'arménie se retire
complètement de notre territoire
il en est évidemment pas question et par
conséquent le combat va continuer alors
ceci avec quand même une réserve c'est
que l'azerbaïdjan n'a aucune intention
d'envahir le territoire de la république
d'arménie
parce que l'arménie en tant que telle
est liée par des accords de défense avec
la russie elle fait partie du traité de
sécurité
coopération et d'autre part il ya une
base militaire russe en arménie par
conséquent à faire battre jean ne
touchera pas à l'armée l'objectif de la
barbade gens c'est de récupérer la zone
tampon contrôlée par l'arménie autour du
nagorny karabakh et le nagorny karabakh
lui même
évidemment ceci n'est pas possible et il
faut ouvrir la négociation négociations
qui n'a pas abouti depuis 22 ans
la france s'y étaient essayés en son
temps en tant que coprésidents du groupe
de minsk et le président chirac lui même
avait tenté d'aider des médiations entre
le président aliyev le père et le
président arménien de l'époque pour
conclure en quelques mots aujourd'hui où
la france si su se situe-t-elle pardon
dans le dossier est bien va jouer
pleinement son rôle en tant que
président coprésidents du groupe de
minsk avec la russie avec les états unis
il est vrai que on voit bien dans la
presse française que la france et voit
plutôt d'un d'un d'un oeil favorable la
cause arménienne
peut-être parce qu'il ya une communauté
franco arménienne qui est assez
importante et que cette communauté joue
un rôle important dans la population
française peut être aussi parce que la
force n'est jamais un moyen acceptable
pour régler un différend internationale
mais ceci étant je pense que la france
garde aussi les contacts avec toutes les
parties dans cette affaire merci
beaucoup claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales